لقد أمضوا ليلة برد
وتبللوا في العراء ولما
أثارت بصيص أمل من تركيا قائلة إنها
لن توقف عبور اللاجئين إلى
أوروبا وتسهيل نقلهم
هنا إلى الحدود مع اليونان ، عبد الله
هو الناجي الوحيد من القصف.  الذي
قتل بقية أفراد عائلته في سوريا
، الجانب السفلي من المهمة الدقيقة التي تم
إصدار فاتورة بها للجمهور الذي اعتقدوا أنه مفتوح
، اعتقدوا أن الحدود بأكملها
مفتوحة ، ليست اليونان لا تسمح لأي شخص بالمرور ،
إنها فوضوية للغاية
، يحاول الأشخاص فقط البحث عن
ما هم عليه  أعتقد أنها ستكون حياة أفضل ،
أوروبا لا تريدهم لم يسبق لهم أبدًا
أن أبرموا صفقة مساعدة مالية
مع تركيا في عام 2016 ولم
تدفع بالكامل أبدًا لوقف فيضان اللاجئين
تركيا التي تستضيف ما يزيد عن 3.5 مليون
لاجئ معظمهم من سوريا منذ فترة طويلة
هددت بفتح البوابات إذا تُركت
لتحمل عبء اللاجئين بمفردها
والآن تركيا غاضبة أكثر من
رفض الغرب دعمها في عيد الحب
مع  أي شيء أكثر من مجرد كلام
، يدرك الكثيرون هنا أنه يتم استخدامها كوسيلة
ضغط ، حيث ينفجر الغاز المسيل للدموع
ويختلط بالدخان الناتج عن حرائق متعددة ، حيث
حاول أولئك الذين حاولوا البقاء دافئًا ، حيث
قُتل زوج سامهيتاس ، أي هزته داعش
، جاءت إلى تركيا مع أطفالها
الأم المسنة  وشقيقها المعاق إلى
أين من المفترض أن نذهب ، ثم
تتجول هذه الأم السورية لا تريد
أن تتحدث عندما نسأل كيف تفعل ذلك ،
إنها تلامس وجه طفلها ،
كل هذا يذكرنا بشكل فظيع
باليأس الذي شهدناه منذ سنوات مع
عبور الحشود عبر أوروبا في
نلتقي في الليل ببعض أولئك الذين حاولوا
عبور النهر إلى اليونان لكنهم فشلوا في
نفي السلطات اليونانية ذلك ، لكن بعض النقاط البارزة
من شفة العيد تقول إن اليونانيين أجبروه على
إعادة مزق بطاقة هويته وأخذ هاتفه
الذي لم يتحدث إلى والديه منذ
حوالي أربعة أعوام.  أسابيع وهم فيها ،
إنهم في المعسكرات ، وهو قلق
عليهم ، والآن لا توجد لديه طريقة
للتواصل معهم ،
تقول هذه العائلة من أفغانستان
نفس الشيء  لقد تم فصلهم عن رجالهم ولكن
الأسوأ من ذلك أنهم انفصلوا عن رجالهم
والدها وأخوك زوجها بخير
هناك وأنت عالق هنا ،
فهم خائفون من الضعفاء وحدهم يحرقون
الملابس المهملة ولا يعرفون إلى أين
يذهبون أو كيف يجدون من يحبونهم.
كان من المفترض أن يفعلوا ذلك عندما أصبح
بؤسهم ويأسهم أكثر بقليل
من سلاح سياسي
أروى ديمون سانون على حدود الشحوم في تركيا.